questa è una bottiglia rotta
ma è anche molto di più è un tesoro è un
oggetto che ha una storia da raccontare
perché non vale tanto quello che è ma
quello che ci si può vedere attraverso
io ci vedo fantasia voglia di fare e un
grande senso di responsabilità la voglia
di contribuirvi contribuire a
ricostruire uno spirito imprenditoriale
per il nostro paese ma per raccontare la
storia della bottiglia prima vi devo
raccontare un'altra storia che mi tocca
più personalmente
mi chiamò e gli hana baruffi e sono una
fan sfegatata di junior achievement
cos'è junior achievement junior
achievement gioia per gli amici è
un'organizzazione non profit che ha come
obiettivo quello di accompagnare i
ragazzi nel loro percorso scolastico
offrendo loro una marcia in più gioia va
nelle scuole e porta delle iniziative
didattiche che aiutano i ragazzi dai 16
ai 19 anni a sviluppare il loro
potenziale
personale e professionale a crescendo il
loro curriculum con delle competenze
trasversali
legate all'imprenditoria
e lo fanno insieme agli insegnanti e
anche insieme a degli esperti d'azienda
volontari che decidono di offrire la
loro esperienza a questi ragazzi quindi
un circolo virtuoso che muove tante
energie proprio pensando al futuro
culturale sociale del nostro paese
proprio quel senso di responsabilità di
cui vi parlavo prima
io ho incontrato junior achievement nel
all'epoca steve jobs lanciava il suo
primo iphone il vhs usciva dagli
standard per la distribuzione
cinematografica
e usciva anche il primo rapporto
sull'impatto dell'educazione
economica sui ragazzi sugli studenti
delle scuole superiori si chiamava
giovani economia e spirito
imprenditoriale
a quell'epoca junior achievement aveva 5
anni aveva già sviluppato un bel
pacchetto formativo aveva raggiunto un
numero considerevole di studenti
io all'epoca come peraltro oggi mi
occupavo di comunicazione nel gruppo abb
è un giorno passando in corridoio vedo
un poster in cui vengo invitata insieme
ai colleghi a offrirmi volontaria per
andare nelle scuole medie a parlare di
economia con un linguaggio che sia
vicino a quello dei ragazzi se c'era una
materia nella quale lo scarsa era
proprio l'economia
come al solito mi sono buttata avevo un
sacco di dubbi avevo paura di non
riuscire a coinvolgere i ragazzi in
maniera proattiva
magari parlando che so di materie
ostiche come cos'è il budget familiare o
come funziona veramente un bancomat
mi ricordo quando sono entrata visto
questi venti ragazzi incuriositi forse
non sapevano neanche che cosa aspettarsi
di fianco a me c'era un insegnante molto
incoraggiante molto accogliente e io mi
sentivo sicura studiare avevo studiato
ero abituata a parlare per motivi
professionali faccio anche l'attrice
amatoriale da quando ero piccola va beh
più o meno come adesso e quindi mi sono
buttata
i ragazzi hanno risposto immediatamente
si sono lanciati in tante domande
pertinenti avevano proprio voglia di
capire quindi esperienza strapositiva
attorno in azienda ne parlo coi colleghi
così fanno anche gli altri volontari e
per la cronaca oggi sono 100 i miei
colleghi che lavorano che hanno lavorato
come volontari per junior achievement
del resto come non innamorarsi di una
esperienza come questa che è vero che ti
porta un po fuori dalla tua area di
conforto però in realtà ti dà la
possibilità anche di tirare fuori il
meglio da se stesso e il meglio dalle
persone che che incontri
questa è una prima storia che vi ho
voluto raccontare adesso però vi voglio
raccontare la storia della bottiglia
attraverso l'esperienza diretta dei
ragazzi che ci hanno lavorato
questi ragazzi hanno guardato nella
bottiglia e ci hanno visto la
possibilità di ridare valore a qualcosa
che sembrava non averne più
hanno preso una bottiglia rotta e si
sono inventati un bicchiere un bicchiere
molto trendy che sa vedere al fondo
della bottiglia sa di tradizione di
artigianalità e quindi hanno trasformato
un relitto in un tesoro questi ragazzi
che hanno fra i 17 18 anni hanno
lavorato durante tutta un anno
scolastico insieme a loro insegnante
agli esperti di aziende hanno messo su
una vera e propria impresa hanno pensato
come recuperare le bottiglie come
produrre bicchieri hanno progettato il
packaging hanno pensato come distribuire
il prodotto al prezzo e poi con un po di
faccia tosta sono andati alla conad a
donoratico e hanno proposto il loro
prodotto la conad a l'apprezzato ne ha
comprati 400 iniziato a venderli nel
loro store nella sezione sapori e
dintorni
questa è una delle storie che io adoro
proprio perché dimostra che si può fare
è possibile fare queste cose io penso
che tu nera cilmente sia un punto di
convergenza fra tanti bisogni e tante
energie che restano a volte inespresse
il bisogno della scuola non solo di
istruire ma di formare i cittadini di
oggi e di domani
dove vogliamo vedere dei giovani che
siano capaci sia di sognare che di fare
il bisogno della scuola stessa degli
studenti delle famiglie di trovare
sempre stimoli nuovi delle leve
motivazionali e allo stesso tempo di
allenare anche la tenacia di questi
ragazzi e non ultima la necessità della
scuola di parlare con l'impresa perché è
importante che allineano i loro progetti
e le loro priorità
insieme ai bisogni come dicevo le
energie la prima
dirompente quella dei ragazzi che avrete
sicuramente intuito
l'energia degli insegnanti che sono la
vera chiave di successo di questo
progetto e l'energia anche degli esperti
d'azienda che hanno il compito di
raccontare ragazzi come funzione
effettivamente un'impresa e hanno
bisogno di insegnare loro che non basta
avere una buona idea per avere successo
bisogna lavorarci bisogna progettarla
bisogna anche renderla economicamente
sostenibile e allora vi assicuro che
fanno quasi tenerezza questi ragazzi che
non per gioco si trasformano in un
amministratore delegato direttore di
produzione direttore amministrativo e in
giacca cravatta e già si presentano
davanti a una giuria di imprenditori per
presentare la loro la loro idea
imprenditoriale
nella mia carriera di fan di junior
achievement di ragazze di idee ne ho
viste le viste passare tante e adesso
sono proprio
orgogliosa di poter guardare questa
esperienza da un altro punto di vista
come neo presidente di junior
achievement e spero proprio in questa
posizione di poter contribuire sempre di
più a questa questa iniziativa questo
progetto insieme ai colleghi che
rappresento da tutte le aziende che
credono in questo progetto che
condividono questa questa responsabilità
voglio però raccontare anche di qualche
dato perché anche i numeri secondo me
possono dare la dimensione del fenomeno
dal 2002 a oggi junior achievement ha
raggiunto 218 mila studenti qua in
italia
3.500 insegnanti e più di 3.000
volontari
ma il numero che ci rende ancora più
orgogliosi è il fatto che il 72 per
cento degli studenti raggiunti da junior
achievement dichiara di essere più
interessato ai temi economici e il 43
per cento dice che ha più fiducia nel
futuro
quindi
ispirare fiducia attraverso l'esperienza
questo è proprio il nucleo del progetto
di junior achievement
allora qua sorge la domanda ma allora se
il modello c'è ed è anche ampiamente
testato se è vero che siamo in un
contesto win win dove tutti gli attori
hanno qualcosa da guadagnarci se è vero
che ci sono tutte queste energie
inespresse che non vedono l'ora di
essere usate ma allora perché non
integriamo questo nuovo modo di fare
scuola subito nel nostro sistema
didattico questo no il nostro sforzo di
oggi questa è la nostra mission quella
di collaborare insieme alle istituzioni
per far sì che questa esperienza possa
contribuire a un cambiamento strutturale
del nostro sistema didattico che come
tutti sappiamo soffre da tanto tempo
anche di mancanza di investimenti
junior achievement
ha voluto esprimere la propria mission
in un manifesto dell'educazione
imprenditoriale sottolineando alcuni
punti il primo l'importanza che i
ragazzi imparino facendo in una scuola
che si apre sempre di più verso
l'esterno
poiché gli insegnanti vedono
riconosciuto il loro impegno e che
possono accedere anche ad attività
formative che li aiutino a sviluppare
queste competenze interdisciplinari che
i ragazzi vedano certificate le loro
competenze possano anche provare queste
loro mini imprese in un contesto che sia
il più vicino possibile alla realtà
magari anche attraverso delle procedure
per registrare i brevetti che siano
semplificate e che quindi consentono
loro di tutelare le loro idee e non
ultimo che i ragazzi possano capire come
affrontare il rischio e perché no anche
affrontare un fallimento perché anche un
fallimento ha qualcosa da insegnare anzi
magari diventa il motore propulsore
dell'innovazione
junior achievement a uno slogan investe
nei giovani e loro faranno il resto è
proprio la sintesi perfetta proprio
quello in cui noi crediamo questa è la
nostra aspirazione
questa è quella che sentiamo come una
nostra responsabilità che ci piacerebbe
anche condividere con nuovi fan di
junior achievement quello che ci spinge
ad aiutare i giovani a far fiorire loro
potenziale a guardare al futuro con
maggiore ottimismo grazie